jean-marie wynants bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions quand vous
évoquez des entreprises dangereuse à
quoi est ce que vous pensez ce que vous
pensez à ce qui s'est passé à lubrizol
du côté de rouen à lubrizol bis ça
pourrait avoir lieu dans votre
département de quoi avez vous peur
exactement mais en fait après après les
défis à peu près une vingtaine d'années
et puis et puis lubrizol un petit peu il
ya un petit peu moins de temps
effectivement on a une inquiétude on est
on n'est pas complètement fermée et on
comprend très bien que ces usines
étaient là bien avant l'augmentation de
des zones urbaines qui se sont un peu
rapproché deux de ses sites pour autant
maintenant il faut qu'on trouve une
solution il est évident qu'on ne peut
pas laisser de ce ce genre d'entreprise
restait alors qu'on a le rer d qui passa
à quelques mètres seulement de ce site
on a eu une
exercice qui a été organisée la semaine
dernière c'est un exercice qui a tout
lieu d'être respectés nous avons
participé à cet exercice avec la
préfecture et avec les autres communes
pour autant le l'exercice qui nous a été
proposé était d'ailleurs un exercice a
minima puisque en cas de grosse de gros
problèmes c'est au niveau régional et
national que les que les secours
s'organisent sans même qu'on soit
directement concernés moi ce qui
m'importe surtout c'est que les
habitations et puis il y à des habitants
qui sont proches de ceux de ses sites et
qu' on ne peut pas se dire qu'on prend
les précautions moi je suis persuadé que
les autres ces deux entreprises
respectent le cahier des charges qui est
le leur dans le cadre de la de la
sécurité des sites pour autant on sait
bien que certaines entreprises
respectent tout à fait les respecte tout
à fait ces procédures ce qui n'empêche
pas malgré tout qu'il y à des drames qui
se passe et on ne peut pas attendre que
des dizaines des centaines de personnes
subissent les conséquences d'un accident
pour pouvoir prendre des décisions je
pense que il faut à un moment donné se
dire que en zone urbaine on ne peut pas
accepter ce type de ce type de cuisine
tout simplement parce que
potentiellement il ya un rejet très
important pour la sécurité de nos
habitants donc vous appelle à des
délocalisations de ces entreprises si on
délocalise on fait quoi des emplois
perdus alors le propre de toute façon il
y aura toujours des emplois alors le
nombre d'emplois est très minime les
entreprises le disent elle même ces
quelques unités de personnes puisque
c'est très automatisé ce type de ce type
d'entreprise et donc c'est pas s'est
passé ça se compte sur les doigts des
deux mains donc on peut pas parler de
problème d'emploi vis-à-vis de ce type
de d'entreprise par contre moi ce qui
m'inquiète le plus c'est que on a quand
même et la scène qui était aux alentours
au bord de l'eau au bord de ce site on a
les lacs de viry châtillon qui sont un
des fleurons de l'île de france pour ce
qui concerne la biodiversité on à l'orge
et le bras mort de morges que 2 de
l'orge qui sont juste à côté et puis
surtout on a quand même de très nombreux
habitants les encore une fois le rer d
qui passe juste à côté et entre
quelques emplois et qui de toute façon
seront délocalisés ailleurs et qui
seront donc nécessaires sur un autre
site et puis la sécurité des habitants
je pense qu'on n'a pas hésité il faut
absolument qu'on pensait d'abord en
priorité à la sécurité de nos habitants
à vos côtés on voit un des personnes qui
manifestent parce qu'ils tiennent à leur
emploi mais donc il ya la biodiversité a
également et vous parliez des habitants
quel est le ressenti de vos administrés
alors vous savez cet exercice d'ailleurs
été assez particulier parce que là les
sirènes qui sonne le sun en fait que sur
le site et donc du coup les habitants de
viry-châtillon n'ont même pas eu
connaissance puisque c'était un site un
exercice d'entraînement le pc de
sécurité de la ville a été mis en place
les et un exam exercice donc quasiment
personne n'a été mis au courant donc la
réaction les derniers jours n'ont pas
d'âme n'a pas n'a pas vraiment été
importante pour autant je pense qu'il
faut prévenir avant même d'attendre que
les habitants sont inquiètent certains
habitants centre sont inquiètes se pose
des questions sur ce type de 2,2
d'entreprises situées à la périphérie
puisque ce site est situé plutôt sur ris
orangis et grigny que sur viry mais pour
autant je pense que tout le monde a pris
conscience de du des dangers que
représente ce type d'industrie en plein
centre de dents dans les centres villes
on l'a bien vu avec avec avec les usines
de toulouse et puis aussi avec les
toutes les tout et tout les ti cats iv
catastrophe qu'on puisse se passer sur
le sujet je pense qu'il ya une question
de 2,2 d'anticiper moi je ne demande pas
à ce que le site ferme demain est parti
il faut travailler avec les maires des
communes de grease de grigny et puis de
ris orangis on n'est pas des des fous
furieux qui demandons d'une fermeture
immédiate on demande à ce qu'on
travaille pour la délocalisation dans
les plus brefs délais malgré tout mais
il faut y réfléchir tranquillement pour
éviter d'attendre que quelque chose de
catastrophique soucieux du rappel
rapidement puisqu'on arrive à la fin de
ce journal est ce qu'elle nous avait une
réponse des autorités notamment une
réponse du préfet de l'essonne par
exemple alors pas donc pas encore j'ose
espérer que le communiqué de presse
qu'on a fait puisse le toucher j'ai
également une organisé une visite du
site avec avec mes élus y compris les
élus de l'opposition de la ville de
viry-châtillon de façon à puisque on
puisse se rendre compte in situ sur la
sur le sur le sur le site réellement
mais je crois vraiment qu'il faut qu'on
pense à l'avenir et l'avenir ce n'est
pas ce type de d'industrie en pleine
zone urbaine telle que viry châtillon
grigny ris orangis merci jean marie
villemin d'avoir à répondre à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes maire
centriste donc de la ville de viry
châtillon en région parisienne c'est la
fin